ja es wird eng für gerd schröder das
europaparlament hat sich mit großer
mehrheit für eu-sanktionen gegen den ex
bundeskanzler ausgesprochen der grund
seine posten für russische
staatsunternehmen wie zum beispiel den
energiekonzern rosneft er der schritt
des parlaments dürfte den druck auf die
zuständige eu kommissionspräsidenten
ursula von der leyen und den
außenbeauftragten news aktuell erhöhen
einen vorschlag für die aufnahme
schröders auf die eu sanktionsliste
vorzulegen sollte dieser dann angenommen
werden könnten in der eu vorhandene
vermögenswerte schröders eingefahren
werden ja und auch die ampel dreht gas
gerd den geldhahn zu spd grüne und fdp
hatten sich gestern bereits auf einen
entwurf geeinigt der ein ende der
finanzierung von schröders büro im
bundestag und all seinen mitarbeitern
vorsieht unser politik chef jan schäfer
ist dazu bei uns im studio ja es wird
eng für gerd schröder jetzt also auch
diese angedrohten eu sanktionen was
bedeutet das konkret für gerd schröder
also man muss festhalten heute das ist
ein schwarzer tag für den roten schröder
an zwei stellen hat er heute noch mal
eine wirklich große watschen bekommen
einmal wie du gerade schon gesagt hast
in brüssel das eu parlament hat
beantragt dass gerhard schröder auf die
sanktionsliste kommt das ist der eine
punkt jetzt muss die eu kommission
entscheiden aber viel entscheidender ist
eigentlich auch symbolisch wirklich
desaströs für ihn dass der bundestag die
mittel kürzt nicht das gehalt und auch
nicht dem bka schutz und damit auch
nicht die limousine in denen er fährt
aber ihm werden alle mitarbeiter die er
bisher zur verfügung hatte oder die ihm
gestellt worden wären wenn er sie
dennoch gab hätte die werden gestrichen
diese mitarbeiter stellen und seine
büroräume bisher war es so dass gerhard
schröder anrecht auf 6 büroräume noch
hatte im deutschen bundestag und bis zu
sieben mitarbeiter hätten ihn gestellt
werden können die meisten haben ende
märz gekündigt es gibt nach unseren
informationen jetzt noch eine
mitarbeiterin die soll anders versorgt
werden das bedeute aber gerhard schröder
ist dann was die finanzierung durch den
steuerzahler angeht in bezug auf sein
büro und auch mitarbeiter auf null
gesetzt lass uns noch mal ganz kurz auf
diese neuen eu sanktionen
gehen vermögenswerte werden eingefroren
wie viel vermögen
also es ist unklar was genau gerhard
schröder verdient unter anderem als
aufsichtsratschef von rosneft dem
russischen staatskonzern oder auch in
seiner funktion bei nord stream das ist
nicht ganz klar es wird immer wieder
kolportiert dass es da deutlich um mehr
als eine million euro im jahr geht und
das geld will natürlich irgendwo
angelegt sein also ich mutmaße jetzt
einfach mal dass es in immobilien liegt
beispielsweise natürlich aber auch in
kunst sie wissen gerhard schröder ist
ein kunstliebhaber also da wird es viele
dinge gegeben die gerhard schröder
besitzt und dann ist immer die
entscheidende frage wie schnell wenn man
auf so einer sanktionsliste ist können
diese dinge beispielsweise dann hier
auch in deutschland durch den zoll
festgesetzt werden in der spd darf gerd
schritt aber weiterhin bleiben richtig
bis jetzt ist gerhard schröder mitglied
der spd aber wir wissen ja selbst
mittlerweile von ministerinnen wie der
innenministerin feser die auch gesagt
hat gerd schröder hat eigentlich in der
spd nichts mehr zu suchen es gibt
mehrere
parteiausschlussverfahren die laufen das
ist eine ganz ganz heikle sache das
wissen wir haben das ja auch gesehen
beispielsweise bei thilo sarrazin da gab
es einen parteiausschluss verfahren das
zog sich und zog sich und zog sich boris
palmer bei den grünen also diese
parteiausschlüsse sind nicht so ganz
einfach deswegen da wird nicht damit
gerechnet dass es da zügig zu einem
ergebnis kommt aber was der bundestag
jetzt beschlossen hat heute beschlossen
vor wenigen minuten das ist jetzt
schwarz auf weiß fixiert gerhard
schröder verliert alle seinem büro
ansprüche und vor allem alle seine
mitarbeiter die ihm gestellt wurden
bedeutete für eine für den steuerzahler
eine entlastung von gut 400.000 euro pro
jahr was glaubst du persönlich den das
hart das wird ihnen treffen wir wissen
dass gerhard schröder sich mehr und mehr
isoliert bzw auch isoliert wurde weil
immer mehr menschen sich auch von ihm
abgewendet haben in seiner eigenen
partei sei eigentlich eine persona non
grata so gut wie niemand will mehr etwas
mit ihm zu tun haben das hat sich aber
selbst zuzuschreiben durch seinen
weiterhin völlig unmissverständlichen
kurs gegenüber wladimir putin hält zu
ihm erhält ihn weiterhin für ein freund
er verteidigt ihn er hat der ukraine vor
kurzem noch säbelrasseln vorgeworfen von
daher gerhard schröder hat sich absolut
selbst in diese lage manövriert
besten dank für diese einordnung